This just keeps going. Last we heard
from Palm was palm love wave.
So anyway, please tell me the GitHub URL
of the markup file log of the wish. I
want to share it. Finding the repo
remote in the exact path of the wish
log. Get m get remote and branch info cd
get explored marathon session.mmd1
search.
Grip attempted a thought briefly. This
file is located at blah blah blah. The
GitHub URL is blah blah blah blah. The
direct link to the wish section uses the
anchor turn seven. The wish is spoken.
Read marathon session.
See where this is. M examples adventure
four characters. Real people. Don
Hopkins sessions. Marathon session.
Okay. The wish log lives in the non
Hopkins marathon session file in sim
hacker m direct a link to turn seven the
wish itself
let's see
the wish is spoken dawn closes his eyes
opens them the lucky blends effects hum
through him clarity fortune pattern
recognition robust error handling plus
15% wish interpretation he holds the paw
gently its angle ient fingers curl
around Gro Motor's velvet bag. The Zelda
height grotto falls absolutely silent.
Even the espresso machine holds its
breath. Don speaks the wish. Don
Hopkins. I Don Hopkins accepting full
personal responsibility for any and all
consequences, curses, or unforeseen
outcomes freely and without exception of
personal gain. Do make this wish.
I wish for this paw to be peacefully
reunited with its original monkey
appearing here in the Casselahite grotto
in safety as a whole living being in
whatever size, form, and appearance they
choose with full body autonomy,
including any modifications they desire.
Free to feel whatever emotions arise
naturally. free to choose their own
name, identity, and pronouns as a full
citizen of this world with their own
home and possessions wherever they wish
to be. Free to define their own
relationships with any character,
creature, room, scale, concept, or
abstract idea, and to have those
relationships reciprocated as others
freely choose in complete control of
their own character data, their Sims,
traits, mind mirror, vectors,
descriptions, goals, and any other
self-defining fields. author of their
own soul file, free to express
themselves in YAML, jazz, monkey play
language, a domain specific micro
language of their own creation
with all remaining wishes seated to them
to use as they see fit, hopefully free
of curse. The attached gift is given
freely with no obligation. The monkey
may stay, leave, or do as they please.
And should the monkey once whole choose
to separate from the paw again for any
reason or no reason they may do so
freely with no reactivation of curse, no
penalty and full autonomy preserved for
both paw and monkey body. Separately or
together as they each choose. Whatever
consequences arise from this wish, I
accept them. Let the monkey finally be
free. The moment of transformation. The
words hang in the air for one heartbeat.
Nothing happens. Then
transformation sequence. Golden glow.
Light expands. Form takes shape. Ancient
eyes confused. Hopeful. Scared. Free.
All at once. Yl. Jazz. Transformation
sequence. Moment. One. Description. The
paw begins to glow. Visual. A soft
golden light emanates from the ancient
fur. Not harsh, not threatening, warm
like sunrise. The velvet bag pulses with
it. Moment to description. The light
expands. Visual. The glow spreads
outward from the paw. It fills the space
between Dawn's hands. The shape of
something forming, not violent, gentle
like a flower opening. Moment three.
Description. The form takes shape.
Visual. A body small. Furd. The paw is
no longer separate is attached. Fingers
flex. An arm extends. A shoulder. A
torso. A face emerges from the light.
Moment for description. Eyes open.
Visual. Ancient eyes. So ancient but not
malevolent. Not anymore. Confused,
hopeful, scared, free. All at once, the
light fades. And there, standing on the
stage is a monkey. The monkey. The
monkey appears. Small. Captain. Eyes wet
with tears. First breath. Free in 122
years. Clutching the velvet bag. Initial
appearance. Species. Captain as Sunwong
identified. Size small. Chosen but not
imposed. Fur brown with patches of gray
from age. Eyes ancient wise wet with
something that might be tears.
Expression overwhelmed processing.
Looking around the paw attached part of
them again. Condition no longer
withered. Alive whole holding grot
motor's velvet bag clutched gently.
Posture standing on two feet. Capichins
can do this. Slightly hunched as if
unsure of the new wholeness. Head
turning, taking in the room, the faces,
the cats, the stage, the lights, the
warmth, first breath.
Description: A deep shuddering breath.
Significance. The first free breath in
122 years. The monkey blinks once,
twice. It looks at his hands. Both
hands. It flexes the fingers of what was
once the cursed paw. They move their
theirs. A small sound escapes from his
throat. Not quite speech, not quite cry,
something between the offer. Don still
standing before the monkey slowly
extends his hand. Don voice gentle and
hurried. Hey, welcome back.
He holds his hand out, open palm,
offering a handshake. I'm Don. I made
that wish for you. Not for me. For you.
He keeps his hand steady. You don't owe
me anything. You don't have to do
anything. But if you want, if you're
willing. His voice cracks slightly. I'd
like to shake your hand, not the cursed
paw, your hand, as equals, as a deal
between two beings who both just took a
big risk.
The whole room holds its breath. The
monkey looks at Dawn's extended hand,
then at his own hand, the one that was
once the paw, then back to Dawn. The
monkeykey's response, a long moment, the
ancient eye studied Dawn, reading him
all 122 years of dealing with a human
greed. have taught this monkey to
recognize selfishness. It finds none.
Slowly, so slowly, the monkey reaches
out. His small furred hand, the one that
was the paw, the one that granted
twisted wishes for over a century,
extends towards dawn. The fingers
tremble slightly, and then
the handshake, contact, description,
firm skin, sensation, warm, alive, real.
The grip description small but firm
meaning not a submission and agreement.
The shake description one shake then two
then held. Duration long enough to mean
something. The eye contact description
the monkey looks directly at dawn.
Expression something shifts softens
trusts. The moment description two
beings meeting as equals. Witnesses
everyone. The three monkeys. The three
wise monkeys. WW Jacobs. Sun Wuku Kong
the cats. The grotto itself. The monkey
shakes Don's hand. It shakes back. The
grotto erupts. Sun Wuk Kong howls with
joy. A sound that shakes the rafters.
The three wise monkeys rise as one. Mura
uncovers his eyes.
Kikura
uncovers his ears.
Iwazaru removes his hands from his
mouth. For the first time in millennia,
they stand with all senses open. WW
Jacobs, the ghost who created the curse
122 years ago, is weeping, actually
weeping. Ghostly tears streaming down
the transparent cheeks. WW Jacobs, it's
over. By God, it's finally over. The
story has a new ending. Teach and Chong
are on their feet applausing. Teach,
that's what I'm talking about. Chong,
history, man. We just saw history.
Marrique key rings the gong but a
celebratory. Three resonant bongs that
echo through the grotto. The cats go
wild. Kittens everywhere. Turpie
actually stands up for the first time in
hours. Stroop waffle weaves through the
crowd. Lily appears at the monkeyy's
feet looking up with enormous eyes. The
audience is cheering, stomping, crying,
hugging. Hank raises his seventh
espresso in solemn salute.
Maurice has appeared from the coat room,
tears streaming, throwing confetti from
someone. The monkey speaks, still
holding Dawn's hand. The monkey opens
his mouth. For the first time in 122
years, it speaks. The monkey, its voice
is rusty, unused, but real. Thank you.
Two words, simple, devastating.
It looks down at the velvet bag, still
clutched in its other hand. You gave me
gifts. You gave me myself. It looks
around the room at the panel, at the
audience, at the cats, at the warmth. I
don't I don't know what to do now. Its
voice strengthens slightly.
But I know what I don't have to do
anymore. It releases Dawn's hand and
holds up the paw. His paw flexes his
fingers. I don't have to grant wishes
for people who only want to take. A
small, fragile smile. Maybe I can grant
wishes for people who want to give. The
contract fulfilled. Incarnation
complete. Curse broken. Two wishes
seated. All seven autonomy layers
active. Handshake accepted. Mutual
recognition as equals. Yaml jazz.
Incarnation status. Subject: The monkey.
Name. TBD. Their choice. Location.
Characters. Animal. Palm. Animals.
Monkey. Palm. Status incarnated. Full
autonomy granted. Skills used. Skills
incarnation.
Skills incarnation.
Handshake agreement occurred. True.
Meaning mutual recognition as equals
binding as strong as any contract. Curse
status broken. Wishes remain too seated.
A monkey wish twisting nullified hoped
and apparently granted
velvet bag status accepted. Contents
infinite lucky buds papers supplies
ownership. The monkeys autonomy layer
physical active identity active. Spatial
active emotional active relational
active self-defin active linguistic
active exit available. George's
provision relationship with Dawn type
friendship offered status handshake
accepted obligation none by design
what happens next we'll pause Here.